(upbeat music)
- You can have a regular normal
body guy with his shirt off
trying to inspire people,
or you can have me,
a guy with no legs and one arm.
(somber music)
My name's Nick Santonastasso,
I have Hanhart Syndrome,
and Hanhart Syndrome
is a rare genetic disorder
which either leaves the
baby with undeveloped limbs
or undeveloped organs.
In my case, it was just
my limbs that were,
you know, affected.
Middle school was like my rock bottom.
I was always asking, you know,
why was I born like this?
Had suicidal thoughts.
Wrestling started me on, you
know, the answer to why.
I had to have standing
ovations when I lost,
and I just didn't understand
because I'm a very competitive person,
I'm like, you're not supposed to cheer on
someone that loses.
After the matches, I'd
have parents come up to me
and be like hey,
my kid never did a sport,
and he saw you today,
and now he's signed up
for all these sports, you know,
because he sees that if you're doing it,
there's no excuse for him not to.
It was like, that's why I'm here,
and I wanted to break
into the fitness industry,
because I was inspired
by these fitness guys
that, you know, sit around
with their six pack
next to their nice car,
but getting into it,
it's much more than that,
it's how you can move people and show them
that, like, living a healthy
lifestyle is not as hard
as you think it is,
especially if I can do it.
My life revolves around, you know,
eating and training and posting.
(camera flashes)
I look at being fit,
I look at motivating
and inspiring as a duty.
I got a message from a UK mom,
she had twins and one of the
twin’s legs had to be amputated,
she said that they watched the videos together
and he goes, like me, mom,
he's like me, mom.
I didn't have that as a kid,
I didn't have someone to look up to.
That kid can you know, oh,
I don't know how to do this,
let me look at Nick's page.
That's why I do this.
(upbeat music)